ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE CONCERNED
THAT WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
LIKE TO DO, THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
LET'S EXAMINE WHERE WE GO FROM
HERE ON BORDER SECURITY AND
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
WE HAVE WITH US TONIGHT BORDER
PATROL AGENT HECTOR GARZA, HE IS
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL.
AND FRANCISCO HERNANDEZ, WHO IS
AN IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
HECTOR, I HAVE BEEN WITH YOU
DOWN ON THE BORDER.
I APPRECIATE THE GREAT WORK THE
MEN AND WOMEN DO.
IT'S AMAZING, HARD, AND
DIFFICULT.
BUT TELL US WHAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW ON THE BORDER.
ARE PEOPLE ABLE TO GET ACROSS?
WHAT IF ALL OF A SET AN 1100
PEOPLE SHOWED UP IN YOUR SECTOR?
SPEAKER WAS HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASE
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASI
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASS
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASA
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASI
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASE
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASA
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASD
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASW
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEASL
BORDER IS THAT CATCH AND RELEAS.
A LOT OF THE OBAMA HOLDOVERS
WITHIN OUR AGENCY ARE STILL
IMPLEMENTING DOSING POLICIES
THAT WERE UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
UNFORTUNATELY IF THIS CARAVAN
MAKES IT TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND MAKE LOTS OF LEGALLY INTO
OUR COUNTRY, THEY WILL BE
PROCESSED BUT THAT MAY WELL BE
RELEASED ON THE NOTICE TO
APPEAR, WHICH MEANS THEY WILL
DISAPPEAR INTO THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES AND THEY WILL NEVER
RETURN TO COURT.
>> Jason: FRANCISCO, WHAT IS
THE CASE, WHY NOT BUILD THIS
WALL?
THE VIDEO WE WERE JUST SHOWING
WAS VIDEO THAT I TOOK WHEN I WAS
DOWN ON THE BORDER.
YOU SEE A WALL AND THEN IT STOPS
AND THEN IT JUST BECOMES BARBED
WIRE FENCE.
WHY NOT BUILD THE WALL?
WHAT'S THE BEST CASE YOU GOT?
WHY NOT PUT ONE UP?
>> OKAY, FIRST OF ALL, PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS HAVE TO REMOVE
POLITICS FROM DOING THEIR JOB.
OUR SHERIFF IN FORT WORTH DOES
THAT RIGHT NOW.
THE PROBLEM IS --
>> Jason: THAT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE WALL.
>> I AM TRYING TO TELL YOU.
>> Jason: I JUST WANT YOU TO
FOCUS ON THE WALL.
WHY NOT BUILD AN ACTUAL WALL?
>> OKAY, LOOK.
WE CAN'T DO IT.
>> Jason: WAIT, WAIT.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN WE CAN'T DO IT?
YOU SAW THE VIDEO.
>> WE TRIED IN 2001, IT DOESN'T
WORK.
THE PROBLEM EYES YOU HAVE THE
REFORM IMMIGRATION LAWS HERE,
THE ONES THAT WE HAVE ARE NOT
WORKING.
YOU ARE RIGHT, MR. BORDER PATROL
AGENT, ARE YOU ARE TELLING ME
THAT I.C.E. AND BORDER PATROL
CAN'T DO THEIR JOB WITHOUT THE
CITIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HELPING?
ARE YOU SAYING YOU NEED MEXICO
TO CONTROL THEIR BORDERS?
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN SAY THAT.
>> Jason: GIVE HIM A CHANCE TO
ACT ANSWER.
HECTOR, WOULD A WALL HELP YOU
ARE NOT HELP YOU?
>> A WALL WOULD HELP OPERATIONS.
>> Jason: THAT'S ALL HE WANTED
TO KNOW.
FRANCISCO, GO BACK, EXPLAIN TO
ME.
THE GUY WORKS, HE SPENT DECADES
SERVING ON THE BORDER.
IT IS EASIER, BETTER FOR THEM TO
PROTECT 2,000 MILES OF THE
BORDER WITH A WALL.
SO WHY NOT BUILD A WALL?
>> LOOK, I'M OKAY FOR BUILDING A
WALL BUT WE HAVE TO LEGALIZE
100,000 MEXICANS TO BUILD IT AND
THAT IS A GOOD START.
THE PROBLEM IS, WE TRIED IN 2001
AND 2002.
IT FAILED AND WE CANCELED IT
BECAUSE OF BUDGET OVERRUNS.
GUYS, LET'S GET ON THE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CRAW FISHING
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
VOTES ON HIS OWN SIDE.
LET HIM FILIBUSTER, CALL THE
BLUFF, DRAW THE LINE IN THE SAND
BLUFF, DRAW THE LINE IN THE SAN
SAND.
>> Jason: LET ME ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
THE REASON YOU NEED DEMOCRATS IS
BECAUSE YOU NEED 60 VOTES IN THE
SENATE.
THE AUTHORIZATION TO BUILD THE
WALL IS THERE, BUT -- HOLD ON.
THE FUNDING --
>> BECAUSE BOTH PARTIES DON'T
KNOW HOW TO REMOVE THE POLITICS
FROM DOING THEIR JOB, JUST LIKE
SHERIFFS.
YOU GUYS ARE ALL FOCUSED ON
YOSEMITE SAM IN ARIZONA.
YOU GUYS NEED TO GET ON THE
BALL.
BORDER PATROL DOESN'T NEED HELP.
I.C.E. DOESN'T NEED HELP.
WE NEED THE LAWS TO BE CHANGED.
DACA HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH ALL
OF THESE FOLKS.
FEES ARE 800, 900 --
>> Jason: WAIT A SECOND.
>> IT'S A NIGHTMARE IT!
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN TO ANY OF
THE COUNTRIES OTHER THAN AMERICA
AND THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT A
CARAVAN --
>> Jason: HOLD ON.
TIME OUT!
>> ARE WE FUNDING THEM?
>> Jason: LET'S GIVE HECTOR --
HECTOR -- HOLD ON.
HECTOR, WHAT'S THE REALITY?
I WENT TO DETENTION FACILITY, I
SAW PEOPLE FROM 150 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES.
THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM JUST
MEXICO.
WHAT IS THE REALITY OF PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER?
>> JASON, THIS IS NOTHING MORE
THAN A RAMPANT ABUSE OVER
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING TO OUR
BORDERS AND MAKING FALSE ASYLUM
CLAIMS.
MOST OF THESE CLAIMS DO NOT
STAND UP TO THE JUDICIAL
OVERVIEW AND THEY DON'T QUALIFY
FOR THE ASYLUM CLAIMS.
MANY PEOPLE ARE FLEEING THEIR
COUNTRIES -- THERE IS NO
DEFINITION --
>> Jason: FRANCISCO, DEEP
BREATHS.
FRANCISCO.
>> DON'T TELL ME YOU CAN'T STOP
THE TRAIN FROM COMING OVER HERE
ACROSS THE BORDER?
OF COURSE WE CAN!
WE HAVE A BUTTON ON THE TRAIN,
WE CONTROL --
>> Jason: IT'S NOT ABOUT
TRAINS.
I HATE TO TELL YOU.
THERE ARE TRAILS -- I'VE BEEN
DOWN THERE, I'VE SEEN IT.
I HAVE SEEN THIS.
YOU HAVE NO >> IF THE BORDER
PATROL CAN'T DO THEIR JOB, THEYA
PATROL CAN'T DO THEIR JOB, THEYE
FANTASTIC, LET THEM DO THEIR
JOB, AND REMOVE THE POLITICS
FROM LETTING THEM DO THEIR JOB.
>> Jason: HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
FRANCISCO, YOU ARE AN ATTORNEY.
YOU GET THIS, YOU UNDERSTAND
THIS.
HELP ME HERE.
WHEN SOMEBODY CROSSES THE
BORDER, THEY DON'T RUN.
I WASN'T SHOCKED WHEN I WENT
DOWN THERE.
THEY CLAIM ASYLUM.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
>> WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR IS
WALLS IN STRATEGIC LOCATIONS OF
THAT WILL SAVE AMERICAN LIVES,
NOT ONLY AMERICAN LIVES, BUT IT
WILL KEEP THE AGENTS FROM
GETTING ASSAULTED FROM A DAILY
BASIS.
NOT ONLY THE OUTCOME OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS, THEY
ARE FALLING PREY TO THE
CARTEL.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING
PUT INTO FORCED LABOR, SEX LABOR
PUT INTO FORCED LABOR, SEX LABO
LABOR --
>> YOU ARE THE LEADER OF THE
BORDER PATROL UNION.
LESS THAN 20% OF THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS BELONG TO YOUR
UNION.
YOU DO NOT SPEAK FOR BORDER
PATROL.
I KNOW BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
>> Jason: HE IS A PART OF
PATROL AGENT.
>> YOU ARE INSULTING THEM BY
SAYING THEY CAN'T DO THEIR JOB.
>> Jason: FRANCISCO AND
HECTOR, LISTEN, THANK YOU.
THIS IS A LIVELY DEBATE.
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO DISCUSS
BUT I GOT TO TELL YOU, I THINK
THE REASON THE DEMOCRATS ARE
FIGHTING SO HARD AGAINST THE
BORDER WALL IS BECAUSE IT WORKS
AND THEY WANT PEOPLE COMING
HERE.
IF YOU CLAIM ASYLUM -- HOLD
ON -- IF YOU CLAIM ASYLUM, THEN
YOU WILL BE ASSIGNED TO A JUDGE
AND IT IS GOING TO TAKE YOU
FIVE, SIX YEARS BEFORE THAT CASE
IS ADJUDICATED.
YES, IT WILL.